part of the world i'm central jersey a
concept that
north and south jersey doesn't even
believe in but central new jersey is a
real thing
uh but still at one point they like i
never heard this
like when i watched it the two other
times before over the course of the last
10 well 20 the show's 20 years debuted
20 years ago last year
so um there's a line at one point in
like i think season four or five where
he
mentions a restaurant from my hometown
in uh new jersey a restaurant called
bars b-a-h-r-s
in there and um he was like put it on
the shore we could eat at bars and i was
like
even though i'm in the entertainment
business and i've
written and and produced and directed
and and
distributed films that have
not only referenced new jersey or you
know
specifically referenced like
people i [ __ ] know by name i put my
house
like the house i grew up in in a movie
that was randall's house and clerks too
and stuff
and yet still like because i wasn't
raised in the entertainment business
because i
i came to entertainment because i used
to just watch entertainment because i
watched a lot of tv and movies as a kid
still to this day if you [ __ ] like
you could blow me out of the water
um simply by referencing a restaurant my
hotel
in my hometown where i'm like oh my god
they know my hometown exists this is so
[ __ ] up it makes it real and [ __ ] like
that
so silly but um i did that for most of
the day and then of course
there was wonder woman to get to and uh
we'll we'll deep dive on that in a
second but uh i was just so
delighted to have something to watch
with my wife that she actually watched
like
all the way through normally she gets up
and [ __ ] does laundry or walks around
and like does it she's got a fitbit
so this [ __ ] all she does is walk like
she's in the lord of the rings movies
and [ __ ]
just constantly moving around it was
good for her you know she's sitting like
[ __ ] seven miles a day
just within our house and [ __ ] like that
that being said the constant movement
means like she live what happened who
was that like she's never really
in for whatever we're watching she's in
and out of it but wonder woman in 1984
she was plopped down on the couch and
there the whole
[ __ ] ride and stuff and now and also
not complaining like oh [ __ ] this movie
uh i had the uh the the twofer of
i think on christmas eve we watched in
it
and then on christmas day we watched
wonder woman in 1984
both of which were i think at least a
good meaty two and a half hours um
uh in one case i completely understood
what i was getting and in the other case
i just kept on wondering am i this dumb
all the time which which one made you
feel dumb
which one tenant yeah like
two warner brothers movies i guess
we don't really have any news today it's
more like this is the wonder woman show
but it sounds like it could be
the warner brothers show because i too
have seen tenet so we could also talk
about tenant
we can should we should we leave
lieutenant
um make him wait for the wonder woman
yeah
good oh what a [ __ ] showman you are
man
before we dive into that i've been
cleaning my office
and i found like some [ __ ]
and i just wanted to share this
with y'all man um
this is a um
this is from warner brothers it is a
warner brothers show
um and it's from i don't know if you can
see the date there
the date is may 15th
mark of 1996.
what i hold in my hand is a 24 year old
warner brothers letter may i read it to
you
please do it it's not addressed to me
it's addressed to my
agent my then agent philip raskin that
endeavor
at then endeavor long before it was
william morris endeavor
uh dear phillip it's time for the
rebirth of a hero
as you know we are making a new superman
film
taking the world's most famous superhero
into the 21st century
the enclosed collection of comic books
forms the basis
of the take outline we would love to
discuss this
with kevin smith at his earliest
convenience
this was the storyline that i was handed
ready alienated from the world he
protects
convinced his relationship with lois
lane is doomed
superman is suddenly defeated and left
for dead by the villain brainiac and
intergalactic genius intent upon
collecting
the best dna in the universe superman
is secretly nursed back to health by his
mentor cadmus
only to discover he has lost his
superpowers as
lois mourns the loss of her love and
brainiac frantically searches for
superman's body
the man of steel returns disguised using
a high-tech bodysuit to fight
while he attempts to regain his
superpowers while battling
brainiac's henchmen parasite and
banshee superman rediscovers his powers
and his love for lois lane in a final
showdown
superman destroys brainiac and saves the
world that he has come to call home
we look forward to hearing him from you
best regards sincerely
jen perrini she was the warner brothers
and vice president of theatrical
productions at the time
this is how i get to that
[ __ ] superman story like this is
literally the path where it begins like
i had a meeting with basil of wanik
well here here it is that that was may
15th
may 16th here's an endeavor letter that
says
uh dear kevin per your conversation with
basilee wanik
basil uh was a warner brothers exactly
now he's a producer he produced like
argo and he produces huge [ __ ] movies
there john wick movies
the john wick movies those are his yes
uh but when i met him he was
like just a creative exec there warner
bros enclosed please
find the script architects of fear
written by charlie haas as well as
the original outer limits episode of
which this
on which the script is based the project
is set up at warner brothers
with tim burton attached to produce so
that was the one that like they
asked me to come in and talk about and
they sent me that they they're like
we're gonna send you that script and
then i was like what else are you guys
doing
and they said oh we're doing superman i
was like [ __ ] superman like tell me
about that
and so they sent me the superman script
to read but
not as a you could come work on this
just as a like check it out but it says
also enclosed is material regarding a
new superman film the project is also
set up at warner brothers
with peter's entertainment attached to
produce i look forward to hearing your
thoughts
uh my then agent philip raskin so this
is from this is 24
and a half year old [ __ ] document
that led to that
other to my [ __ ] superman story me
writing superman and then nothing
happening with it and me telling that
story for like the next 20 [ __ ] years
and stuff
it's crazy i've been finding all sorts
of [ __ ] like i've been cleaning out
some trunks that were here in the office
and i found like the
if you plan to shoplift let us know sign
that was on the register and clerks
and i was like this must have been from
jay and zombop's strike backer clerks
too
clearly it couldn't have been from
clerks but on the back is the clerk
shooting schedule
like [ __ ] handwritten or typed on a
piece of paper that says april 2nd so
i'm like oh my god this is the real
[ __ ] thing
but this is [ __ ] kooky and then so
this was all may
may 16th may 15th of 1996.
then i got an inter office memo here
also from warner bros that says the
above listed screenplay is highly
confidential
and is for your eyes only please return
it to me on monday
february 10 1997. my office is building
two
room 131 and um this was like the
superman script going into distribution
um and here are the people that got a
copy of the script michael andrine bob
daley
bob daley dude as in like terry semel
semolin daily and [ __ ]
he's also on the list terry semmel
lorenzo
pana ventura lorenzo was the head of the
studio at that point or
you know head of production bill gerber
tracy glazer
paul golding rob growlnick basler wanik
jeannette khan she was the publisher of
dc
um tom lasalli jen perini john
peters he of the [ __ ] the story diana
rathbun
jeff robinov he had just joined the
studio at that point he would later
become the
head of production at one point he was
just he'd been an agent he was coming
from the agency world uh
courtney valente and lionel wiggum so
nuts man like these are the documents
that like
you know forms what what
what are now like these stories that i
tell oh yeah i did this once and like
it's nice when i finished it like this
because i'm like oh proof
that it happened because so often it's
just a story
and nobody's ever been like i challenge
the details of this story
i think you're full of [ __ ] but like i
remember when that documentary when
schnepp's documentary came out like the
death of superman lives what happened
i felt so [ __ ] vindicated because
peters is in the documentary and like
i've been telling that story for like
over 10 years at that point and then
people were like that guy's worse than
the way you
[ __ ] described him and i was like
it just makes me so happy like i know it
it happened i found a [ __ ] cover
letter i'm trying to find it now
for they sent me scott rudin sent me
cavalier and clay
like back in the early here the amazing
cabin for our conversation
please find the amazing adventures of
cavalier and clay written by michael
chabon
the project is set up at paramount with
scott rudin producer
and it was like what do they call
galleys
three volumes this [ __ ] thick man
um so at one point apparently somebody
was like let's
let's [ __ ] he knows about comic books
let's see if if he'll want to do it
here's another letter
dude i don't even remember this [ __ ]
april 3rd 2000.
dear phil to phil raskin from image
movers from jen perrini so she had
moved on to a different company um
image movers yeah i guess that makes
sense right
listen to this because i've never heard
of this [ __ ]
as discussed here is the script to
the fly by paul
and chris weitz for kevin smith's
consideration to rewrite and direct
you ever heard of this movie
me neither and apparently they offered
it to me to direct
i want to go back in time in the year
2000 and be like take the [ __ ]
job like listen to this um
the script is inspired by a 1959
comic book of the same name by joe simon
co-baby daddy of captain america
as you know chris rock is interested in
starring
i could have made a [ __ ] joe simon
comic book movie in the year 2000 10
years before this [ __ ] was popular again
with chris rock as my lead who knew we
are extremely excited about this movie
which we see tonally tone wise
as an action comedy in the vein of men
in black
with a dose of social commentary that
makes it totally unique
and the script currently is a bit broad
both we and chris would like to make the
comedy smarter
and subtler why they came to me i have
no [ __ ] idea
again because i was the person that
talked about comic books
we'd also like to better define the
world and the rules of the spider and
fly people
more importantly however we'd like to
know what kevin smith thinks
best regards jen perrini it was written
by the whites brothers
i i was not paying attention for most of
my career
you know what i was paying attention to
was
um it was a dreamworks movie it was set
up at dreamworks with image movers
attached to produce
and chris rock set to star um i was so
busy paying attention to kevin smith
movies
that whenever somebody was like hey do
you want to make a movie
i was like what and then one day
somebody said it and i said uh okay and
it was [ __ ] cop-out
like go figure i feel like you should
definitely keep all this [ __ ] organized
because at some point there's going to
be either
the kevin smith letters that you
contributed to the library on a
university campus somewhere
or an auction because you're broke and
you're like hey you know what i need
a [ __ ] i can get like a couple grand
for this clerk sign
let me tell you something here's a
little bitters i found this letter as
well
from endeavour it's cover letter came
with a [ __ ] script
um i didn't know
i did not know this what i'm about to
read you
and not that i didn't remember that like
i just
i didn't know and but based on when it
was may 15
2000 that would be
us with the clerk's cartoon just about
to
[ __ ] debut and then get killed so
that's probably where my head was
um maybe fifteen two thousand
dear kevin excuse me per our
conversation
enclosed please find the above mentioned
screenplay for rat race
the project set up at paramount is being
produced by jill tanner
cody chubb and jim jacks jim jacks was a
producer on
on on maulrath jerry zucker is attached
to direct
this movie came out if you respond to
the material
jerry and jane jenkins the casting
director
would like both you and jason muse
to play the roles of blaine and dwayne
please look over page numbers are
5 and 68 and 69.
sincerely jonathan perry um now
i never saw rat race and i'll tell you
why
it opened on the same day as jay and
zombob strike back and it
it outgrossed us like on friday we were
the number one movie and then on sunday
night when they put out the finals we
were like
number three and rat race like did
better than us
and stuff so not only does it like
[ __ ] like oh my god
i like i was we were offered a [ __ ]
role
in something like it's not like you know
come audition it's like we'd like you
guys to play
blaine and twain i could have had i
could have been
we could have me and muse could have
been in two movies that came out that
weekend
like what a mind bender that was man
it's nuts
so my point in all this kids
save your [ __ ] like you'll never know
when it'll come and
come in like crazy handy they offered me
a view from the top
to rewrite that remember the [ __ ]
gwyneth paltrow stewardess movie
it's nuts dude i've been like tiptoeing
through my past going like this happened
this happened which says to me
that i have had like what what a
wonderful career i've had
doing the things i want to do making
kevin smith movies which haven't really
mounted much but like
i [ __ ] love them because i like
people came up to me with like legit
offers to do other things and i was like
are you kidding me i'm gonna be making a
walrus movie get out of my [ __ ] face
no regrets whatsoever but like you know
it's nuts
it's crazy but to be fair like i may not
have known about some of these and stuff
but like there are ones that i've known
about which
obviously because i make the choices in
most cases
but like the one that like i think about
and never regret and i don't think about
it like ooh if only
but i do think about like being offered
good will hunting
and i knew that like i couldn't do it
justice i was like why don't you guys
just direct it because you guys wrote it
and they're like they're not gonna let
us do it they're barely letting us act
in that [ __ ] and you know i was like
well if i directed it i would just be
turning around you guys the whole time
being like what did you see when you
wrote it all right let's do that
because i believe the writer is king so
i was like no
i love the script but you should get
somebody like real to do it and they
loved
gus because um like casey affleck had
worked with gus on to die for
and so ben and matt knew him through him
and and they were like we love gus so
gus was like the absolute right guy and
[ __ ]
but like there were moments where like
you know in that
ins to reference gwyneth paltrow twice
in this podcast
in a sliding doors kind of way like
i could have had a different career and
and i i can't say that it might not have
been more successful
but i i honestly love the kevin
smithiness of my
career the weird roller coaster and it's
not at the end of the day like in my
mind it's like this
amazing roller coaster and viewed from
the outside
world it's probably more like those
kitty coasters that don't really do much
like you know at the fair and [ __ ] it's
not like
lightning loops or some such [ __ ] but at
the end of the day it's my [ __ ]
roller coaster and i'd rather [ __ ]
ride build and ride my own roller
coaster than [ __ ]
i guess the metaphor fell apart but you
know what i'm getting i know what you
mean i mean i think that
there's also something lovely about the
fact that
you know and it's tragic in its own way
that it's really really hard
to have the kevin smith career anymore
because
they don't make movies that are just a
dude has a story he wants to tell
it's can you do the fly can you do this
can you do that
we're making this would you like to take
a swing at that and all of which could
be great and lovely and wonderful but
they're never
your things anymore um so true
i i don't know it can't it ain't
possible anymore because i [ __ ]
i locked the door behind me once i got
in the room man i
covered the path i was just like [ __ ]
i'm here [ __ ] everyone else
um you know what else i've been doing
all for the holiday eating like a
[ __ ]
son of a [ __ ] man but i guess that's
what you do uh
but i i uh yeah it's time to stop that
[ __ ] i've been having far too good of
time with food
vegan though it may be a lot of it has
sugar in it and stuff
so as we also got smacked at how much of
that
stuff is actually paper that you're
saving you know because i
i even as late as like 2 000
like [ __ ] were sending emails
like lots of [ __ ] candy
it's not like some brand new invention
but you still got
full-on hard copies of [ __ ] yeah it's
crazy man i've
hear those are like letters like they
were printed and then
put on top of [ __ ] scripts and stuff
i got
[ __ ] here these are
faxes that are heat transfers
old rolly paper and [ __ ] that then has
to be cut
and stuff like the dates on these faxes
are
january 6 1997.
they're like screening reactions to
chasing amy
like in advance of us going to sundance
they start showing it to like some of
the long lead magazine press and stuff
so like l and gq and stuff i still have
this [ __ ]
like i [ __ ] keep it all man you know
what i found which was delightful
was the coverage that a studio person
did oh i got it right here
the studio person you know a studio
job i don't know if they do it anymore
but remember coverage where the
[ __ ] would read your script and then
write a book report on it essentially
because people at the studio were too
busy and couldn't be bothered to read an
entire script
so they would read the [ __ ] cliff
notes version of that script and it's
called coverage
this is coverage um written
in uh october 16 1996
written by susan craig story analyst
susan craig
based on my 45 page
treatment for superman lives
so not the script the the treatment um
and this is the one liner like uh it
says superman lives by kevin smith
type meaning type of movie action
adventure comedy romantic
locale in time metropolis los angeles
other planets contemporary theme
superman battles brainiac who teams up
with lex luthor to kill the man of steel
and subjugate the earth
but superman has friends he's aided by
shape-shifting eradicator
who guides him like dad jarrell and his
true lois who leads a rebellion against
luthor's attempts
to strip their freedoms and destroy
their hero
[ __ ] that that movie sounds no um
so most of it is like a book report that
breaks down my old
superman script but then when you do
coverage there always comes
the opinion part this is what susan
craig
wrote about superman lives
in 1996 october of 96 ready
kevin smith is an inspired choice
to relaunch the superman franchise why
the [ __ ] isn't susan craig running [ __ ]
at warner brothers mark
clearly this is a woman ahead of her
time she's in
she saw the future in this documentary
in his own rebellious rock and roll
human-oriented way
he has succeeded in reinventing the man
of steel
by reminding us of what a hero is
and why we need one in every way this
treatment is a tantalizing promise of
good things to come
lois smartly knows clark kent is
superman they want a family but need to
find the time
superman feels welcomed by earth's
acceptance of him
even though he's an alien his affection
for his adopted home is clear
convincing and even moving uh
now the battle is to keep fascists out
of power
and freedom in sight even the daily
planet suffers at the hands of the
villains who fear the truth of their
exploits
will be exposed and therefore go after
lois in the free press
the struggle is to keep brainiac from
overtaking the world via mindless
technology while trickster lex luthor
works in tandem to fool everyone into
believing they need protection from a
false enemy
while he shields the sun and becomes the
lone source of energy for sale
streamlining the story allows the
collision of forces to stand for more we
now see via lois and jimmy's rebellion
that superman stands
for the spirit uh to keep the world safe
one of the most appealing aspects of
this treatment is the balance between
human elements
and huge hardware action type elements
between suspense and humor
between battling the bad guys and
watching intriguing relationships
like superman and the eradicator and
superman
and lois unfold because this story grows
out of likable characters
who share convincing ideals this one has
a star-warsian greatness to it
susan [ __ ] craig mark
is the smartest person in hollywood what
did
this was in 96 i hope to god susan craig
like became a
studio head that i just didn't hear
about or something
or maybe she maybe she became susan
somebody else like you know she got
married or divorced and lost that
[ __ ] name
what famous susans have been in our
business
susan sarandon
mark susan sarandon wrote this review
[Laughter]
um star wars greatness she said my god
subversively funny and filled with a
kind of we can make the world a better
place team commitment
this story auto appealed on a worldwide
basis
gratefully there is nothing goofy or
campy about this solar powered superman
who knows who he is and what he wants it
is also delightful that some traditional
values are so beautifully surrounded by
an emphasis on things
that are very contemporary such as
computers
holographs shape-shifting etc
in the first draft the cable computers
this efficient treatment sees superman
in a witty human way
with a unique vision that is evident in
the storyline the characters the
dialogue
perhaps most telling the tone it
promises to recharge the franchise with
wit
wisdom eye-popping visuals and a rowdy
sense of good fun
as the hero faces the biggest challenge
of all the loss of freedoms that make
life worth living
bro doesn't that sound like a good
[ __ ] superman movie
it either sounds like that or that susan
craig really wants to like lock you in a
basement somewhere
i feel like there was a missed
opportunity with susan craig i would
have convinced her to become my agent or
something like that
or my story editor or a [ __ ]
co-writer
she saw she understood she got me man
so many in town didn't get me like susan
greg just
got me um how delightful was that to
read years later
star warsian i was like but even now
it doesn't make me go like man i wish
that it happened because like
i got more value out of it i feel i will
never know but i still got infinite
value out of it as a
anecdote that i told through years and
not doing it also like let me continue
to be
you know oh he's on the edge like he's
he's not part of the system man he's
fighting it man you know what i'm saying
like i i look forward
to the uh it's a wonderful life
version of kev when like man you know
nobody ever saw me for what i
am well it just so happens when we can
visit
the other version of you and then you
get the version where you just
said yes to all of those things i'll be
honest with you i assume this whole time
that you were my angel and that's what
we've been doing it's just [ __ ]
looking back
i am your magical black friend kevin
every time a bell every time uh what is
it
who every time who makes who does the
shavers is it not
native does the deodorant who does the
oh manscape
every time you hear a manscaped razor
snap on an angel gets its wings
manscaped not a sponsor this week but we
love them regardless
um yeah man nuts nuts that's the [ __ ]
i've been finding
um all right but speaking of warner
brothers indeed
warner brothers is responsible for two
pieces of big entertainment that just
hit recently
um uh and we all know
what they are tenet home video
officially
hit home video not hbo max um and wonder
woman
1984 debuted on hbo max
uh on christmas day so as we were
talking about before we dove into that
[ __ ]
should we start with tennant let's start
with tim and you know we are probably
going to spoil
um these films not insanely
especially in the case of tenant because
i still don't know most of what happened
so it's hard to spoil a thing that you
don't understand i was going to say i
can't spoil tenant because i'm like i
still don't know if i understand tennant
whatsoever
um but yeah how about you go go first
antenna because i just talked up a blue
streak
um yeah i mean i i i was really eager to
watch canon i mean i wanted to watch it
in the summer but we couldn't because of
i went so far as to uh try and rent out
a theater
in like just before or after
thanksgiving
and like literally spend 250 bucks and
watch the movie just because
i'd really like to watch a movie and b
this was the only really new movie that
one could walk i'm like i'm gonna
[ __ ] watch it
i'm gonna go sit here in the movie
theater jay-z style and just watch
tennis she didn't come together did you
do that didn't you rent a theater
jt did i never did i rented a
theater and watched jurassic park just
uh like the week before the baby was
born
i took jen out for like our last date
night
without without child it was like a
hundred bucks [ __ ] hey man
so mark what stopped you from pulling to
jc and just renting out a whole place
it was literally like the week i was
going to do it
suddenly there was a new spike in los
angeles and uh
and started to get a little like do i
do i trust the theater that they claimed
it do i trust it i mean i trust nobody
else will be in there
but like it was just enough that it made
it
and i would consider you educated man
smart individual
um not i don't think of you as a [ __ ]
risk seeker or anything like that
common sense you always tend to display
if that
is your reaction to the idea of going to
a movie theater and you work in this
business
that's got to be what everybody [ __ ]
feels in general
which is why you know when tennis came
out
it was not the movie that saved the box
office now to be
fair i i don't know what movie could
could have saved the box office in the
middle of a pandemic
it seemed like a fool's errand but i
guess because he wanted to get his movie
out there sooner rather than later
warner brothers went for a theatrical
release with tennant
they did you know and it the more i
watched tenant the more i thought about
it
the more i was kind of i'm not going to
say angry because angry is the wrong
word
but the idea that this is the movie that
would have saved movies
is kind of insane to me because watching
it
you know it is so cerebral
and not in a clear and concise and and
well-explicated way like i got no
problem with smart movies
i have no problem with movies that ask a
lot of me
but i need a movie to meet me halfway
and kind of at the very least
tell me what it's about and i kept on
thinking back to inception
which is you know another christopher
nolan kind of mind bender
where you know what's this about it's
about when the you know we can go inside
and out of dreams and we can travel
throughout them and we can
manipulate thought within them but there
are things
that just tell you what they're doing
like here we are
me and and you know then ellen page
you know let's let's talk about how this
works let's talk about why you can't do
this
as some other things you can do the
things you can't do we'll talk about how
you wake up from a dream you call it the
kick
interview all of these things so that
when you get to that action later on
it all makes sense to you and you
understand it the first time
i would say to be fair the first
inception is a wonderful movie and
you know we're not here to [ __ ] say
one raise one and lower the other but it
it is a movie that like is so
well done that you forgive the fact that
half of the movie is literally people
telling you
what's about to happen just all
exposition
so that when it happens you're like oh
okay and then he turns over
to cinema he's still cinematic when
everyone's talking
but like you know all that exposition
like
could have been a kevin smith movie
there's so much talking but the big
difference is while they're talking
buildings are [ __ ] folding on
themselves and stuff like that
so when you get to the second half of of
uh
the flick or even the you know once
you're past the first quarter or
whatever once the
expository section has been taken care
of
then he just lets loose cinematically
and you everyone seems to accept
and understand the rules of this [ __ ]
science fiction pseudoscience now
tenet didn't seem to pull that off
for me like right off the bat whereas i
was like
i understand the science behind
inception and i you know even though i
know this is
unreal and you can't do it in the
confines
of this world i this makes sense to me
like just like in the invisible man
when he had a [ __ ] high-tech suit
with mirrors i was like that [ __ ]
makes sense it they can't do it it's
fake but like
that there's a logic to this and stuff
so
tenants logic you know i i
i watched it with my wife so that i
could be like did you understand she's
way smarter than me when it comes to
[ __ ] like that
and i you know it just didn't set up its
rules as cleanly
as inception did so most of tenet i felt
i was trying to play ketchup going
wait what no wait what whereas on
inception i understood it every step of
the way and it doesn't mean that like oh
i predicted it not at all
but as you know plot twists
and and contrivances are thrown at you
as the movie shifts like the puzzle box
you know still you're able to hold on i
you know it's like it was like riding a
mechanical bull and holding on the whole
time whereas
like tennant is a mechanical bull
like on overdrive and it's even tough to
get on it let alone stay on it i felt
is that yeah and it's like in every
scene that you're in
it's hard to say that it's a bad thing
you know it's like oh
this is really well done and sure i i i
never executed everything is elevated
incredible cinematography
brilliant filmmaking nobody's taking i
ain't saying like he's a hack not at all
and
and the scenes work and the performances
work and the score
everything about it is cinematic and it
feels big
and stuff like that but but
you know like in its and i think nolan
went on record at some point and saying
that this is the bond movie he always
wanted to make
but they would never let him make a bond
movie which is also a little bizarre to
me because
like traditionally you wanted a british
director to make fun of me the british
director
the biggest filmmaker on the planet
wants to make a james bond you let that
[ __ ] make a james bond
yeah but so this is his bond and
and and uh john david washington who i
like quite a bit
is basically playing his james bond even
though he never gets a name
he's just the protagonist even in the
credits which you know
like a little [ __ ] but whatever but
bob movies very clearly a
tell you who your main character is and
then m will sit him down and say
well bond there's a guy in sweden who
loved
gold and so he's stealing all of the
world gold and we need you to stop him
and he'll say well what's the problem
like what's the what are the stakes and
he'll say well if he crashes the world
economy and he's the only person who
holds the gold and every government will
be beholden to him
you're like oh [ __ ] that's bad you
should go do the things now james
bond and then off he goes it's the it's
the same scene in raven's lost ark
when you lay the pipe of tell me army
men
what is he after well hitler's digging
in the desert looking for this
what is this that's why we're here to
talk to you after the cover that oh
[ __ ] the army that holds the ark before
it is unbeatable i get it now
there's no such scene independent so
that why is he doing these things
why aren't he chasing this lady into you
know india
why is he going here what what is this
turnstile about
and kenneth brennan is clearly playing
the big bond villain
but we don't know what he wants either
he's like is he does he want a family
back it doesn't seem like it does he
want power we're not sure why he's
already got the dragon yeah so what does
he need
and then they start talking about
inversion and entropy
and and being able to reverse the flow
of time and
and there's a temporal war i was like
but what does that mean
how does that affect the average person
how does that affect
your hero and i kept on asking these
questions and the film seemed
uninterested in answering them and i
i um
i got a comment here that i just have to
share real quick
eric mai said we could tell when kevin
is reading the comments
they caught me
they caught me because i mean you were
easy to follow
but the movie you were talking about
less so and so i was like well let's see
what they're saying in the comments
section
and that's kind of how i felt like
through most of the movie i'm like
everyone's fantastic at their jobs here
but i in service of what i'm not sure
like the story who was here i hate to be
this
type of idiot who was
and spoilers if you haven't seen tennant
folks
who was the bad guy who was sending the
bullets back through time
unclear you know
there there is some other version maybe
of kenneth branagh who's doing this [ __ ]
but it never becomes clear i don't it
can't be him because he's meant to be on
the boat
like we didn't see the looping moment
where he was the guy
i don't i don't know it was honestly as
you were describing it as you were
talking
i was like oh yeah that did happen that
did happen it was
it's not to say that like it was
forgettable
it wasn't but i don't remember much
you know what i'm saying i remember the
plane going through the building and
being like well that looked
[ __ ] expensive um and
i think merlin was so enamored with
the like looking backwards [ __ ] which i
imagine is really hard
to shoot and really hard to execute but
on screen
it's not that cool at the end of the day
the avengers kick thanos's ass in a
dozen different ways but this is just
and did he i i didn't follow closely
enough
did he he made people go in reverse in
real life he didn't just reverse the
film
i think there's a mixture of both of
those but i think a lot of it is like
we're reversing the film and we're
shooting another plate where our heroes
going forward through time and then the
background is going backward through
time
and like this building is exploding
while it's being rebuilt because time is
all
like matching on and up against each
other
which from an academic perspective like
oh that's impressive
and i imagine it was really hard to
produce and i imagine other filmmakers
are like how did you do that
but the audience is like oh that car is
just driving backwards
that's that's the thing like i'm a
[ __ ] filmmaker not a good one and not
nearly as good as [ __ ] chris nolan of
course but
i'm sitting there watching the movie
going like
could they couldn't have just ran the
film backwards to accomplish this
like it's because that's what it looked
like at the end of the day it didn't
look like oh this is [ __ ] like you
know
like when i saw t2 and i saw the you
know the [ __ ]
you know t1000 [ __ ] morph for the
first time i'm like holy [ __ ]
like this just had the effect of like
they're driving backwards i guess or
they're running the film in
in reverse yeah it was yeah
and i couldn't figure out
it just wasn't going in reverse is not
impressive enough to sustain a whole
movie in
2020. like maybe in 1960
if you were like look at this [ __ ]
everyone's going backwards people be
like holy
[ __ ] you know because you're talking
about people who in a couple years
they'd be like
tv can be in color too so like
technology
little builds like that would blow their
mind but like watching people go
backwards in 2020
didn't fill me with a sense of wonder
like you know and again i'm not like
saying it ain't inception but like
inception's visuals were incredible and
trippy
and like sucked you into the movie but
even in the trailer when they showed
things happening in reverse
it didn't grab me where i'm like i gotta
see that [ __ ]
but like watching paris like loop in on
itself inception like oh [ __ ]
that's cool and even just the basic idea
of inception which is
um i get to walk around in other
people's dreams like there's a sense of
which fulfillment there there's a
there's a vicariousness
of i wish i could do that on the part of
an audience
and in this it's like i wish i could
drive backwards
i guess you know what's also really
strange too
is that um
i don't think this like is i'm not
saying i'm saying for me i was lost but
i i couldn't tell you what leonardo
dicaprio's character's name and
inception is
um but i think even being
even having said that i i think calling
your main character
protagonist or what was he called was
that it yeah in the credits
and even you know the whole movie kept
going on the protagonist like
it just i don't know there it felt like
a like a there's an academic
remove there to some degree did i freeze
yeah i mean
and and there's no he's got no emotional
drive like he doesn't
want anything you know like he he learns
some stuff
but he doesn't change as a result it's
it's very james bond because bond
also doesn't learn anything or grow at
the end of any one of those movies
but bond is cool you know like james
bond is super [ __ ] cool like
unmistakably cool
and protagonist not
that cool because he doesn't actually do
cool [ __ ] cool [ __ ] happens around him
all the times and occasionally
that's up for debate but he's not the
engine of that cool
the way that sean connery or daniel
craig
or you know timothy dalton or roger
moore was the reason why those movies
were cool
and without that it's just a guy kind of
walking through [ __ ]
i'm happy for him he gets to clearly he
gets to
make whatever he wants to make and god
bless that's awesome
and you know like it's like as we said
it's not like
you look at the movie and go like
[ __ ] they're all a bunch of hacks and
jerks no
everyone's working at the top of their
craft and [ __ ] um
it just you know at the end of the day
it didn't
i i don't remember that much about it it
didn't leave
a lasting that lasting an impression
it's not me going like and therefore
it's bad and wrong and sucks not at all
there's if you haven't seen it
i suggest seeing it um you know you can
see if you're
as befuddled as i am or see if you're
smarter i've seen lots of people online
who are like this is
fantastic nolan at his best so clearly
you know standards i mean mileage may
vary
as they say um i it you know
and again it's not meant to be like this
an inception but i think inception still
for me
feels like his most ambitious and most
successful
movie his movie like those the batman
movies i understand he wrote and
directed but that's somebody else's ip
i think of films like tennant and and uh
um inception interstellar
that's the following uh memento these
are
chris nolan's like true films the ones
that come
from from him not and i don't want
people out there look he said he didn't
[ __ ] direct batman
no of course he directed the [ __ ] out of
those movies but that's somebody else's
[ __ ] he just got to tell really cool
stories with somebody else's characters
but nolan's uh repertoire of non-batman
stuff
clearly is his head can and stuff that's
what he that's what's in his head and
heart
and um you know he's still done
way more better films than not you know
he's still
[ __ ] king and stuff but this one i
i was i'll tell you this much when when
the credits rolled i was like
i'm glad i watched that here i think i
enjoyed it much more
watching it in my home um than i would
have if i was at a theater
especially if i'd gone out like in covid
and [ __ ]
and i saw that it would it would have
made me judge the movie on a different
level altogether where i'm like i risked
my
life to see this like whereas watching
it at home in the comfort of my home i
was like
totally watchable movie um wondering
how it would have done if there hadn't
been a copic
like if there had just been if this 2020
was a regular year
and you had your standard like parade of
blockbusters from
you know march all the way until august
how we would have found the experience
of watching
tennant in theaters after having seen
[ __ ]
like black widow and passing the furious
nine or eight or wherever we are
you know after we had seen some like
real giant
[ __ ] explodo blockbusters at the
movies and then got to this
and been like oh well it's interesting
you know but i don't know if it's like i
gotta tell all my friends to go see it
because i don't know
actually what i'd be telling them to go
see you know i feel like word of mouth
on this might not have helped it
um in theaters and word of mouth and
good word of mouth is the only way
you make a billion dollars is by people
like loving it and telling other people
to go see it
um and i don't know if this movie gets
that
what see anyone know what he's doing
next
um i don't think so i mean he's crazy
secretive about these things
like i think we only discovered what the
hell 10 it was when we saw our first
trailer for it
oh and like patents and let's slip that
he was in a nolan movie
um mark andrezak
said what is your favorite chris nolan
movie
not counting the batman movies i think
we may be
pushing those aside but um
i mean i think i like memento i think i
you know
at its core you know that emotional
story of this guy looking for the murder
of his wife
because it's all that he has left and
spoilers he discovers it
and then changes it so we can keep
looking for it for this murderer
is just so sad and just so you know
it's haunting that it's the mystery that
kind of played in reverse
and you realize again is his fixation
with with
bending of time is right there from the
jump
but i think it's emotionally and even
story logic lies it's the one that holds
together
for me is the best i think i'm an
inception guy
i like prestige a lot but i also
remember being like [ __ ]
you know what confused about prestige
i thought the i mean i didn't like see
the
twin coming spoilers because
i was like oh you're allowed to cheat i
didn't know that like
but knowing that was possible i probably
i might have guessed twin
secret twin but like um
but i think inception is just brilliant
and yeah when you factor in
the batman stuff like the dark knight
and batman begins and
and uh dark knight rises you know it
that to me is like the mark the mark of
his brilliance i i love his
his movies that he's done like the ones
that come out of his head
i mean they all come out of his head but
his movies but
where i think he was incredibly
successful
was you know taking what could be
considered
fairly goofy ip you know of like there's
a guy who dresses up
and turning it into a cop movie he
turned it into a cop movie where the cop
just happened to wear like this
protective [ __ ] suit and a cape and
stuff
made it like real serious made it
believable you know i
like we were coming off the tim burton
joel schumacher era of batman
then i'll never forget seeing batman in
1989 in a theater and being like oh my
god it's so dark and realistic
and then when you get to batman begins
and then later even better
the dark knight he creates this like
world where you're like this [ __ ] could
really [ __ ] happen like oh my god
this is what it would
be like and and that i'll forever be
grateful
for because it you know preached the
gospel
of batman to the masses
but in a practical way that could let
the character
live on you got to remember this was all
in the wake of the george clooney
batman the you know joel schumacher
batman and robin
and at that point people were like well
i guess that's all over with
you know nolan found a way with oddly
enough jeff robinov the guy whose name
was i mentioned before
because he was a big he was the one that
brought he brought chris nolan in to do
you know it was the movie with al pacino
and and um
oh right insomnia he brought him in to
do that that's how he got to warner
brothers
and then from there it was batman and
stuff so
you know i i it's that's a guy who
as a batman fan i'll forever be grateful
because he saved [ __ ] batman
not saying like batman was [ __ ] dead
and he was never coming back but this
dude like
breathed legit life into that character
and then
you know we tend to maybe forget now
because we've had 10 years of amazing
marvel movies but like
with the dark knight you know makes a
billion dollars and gets
like oscar nominations that was a
historic [ __ ] film
and based on like you know [ __ ] oh
this is yet again a story about a guy
who dresses like a bat who
fights a guy dressed like a [ __ ]
clown and still he found a way to make
it smart and [ __ ] like that so
yeah he's obviously a genius filmmaker
[ __ ] man what he was able to pull off
with the batman
that that for that he'll always have my
my utmost affection and respect as a
filmmaker although i'm sure a lot of
real sunnis and maybe film twitter would
be like uh
liking his batman stuff is like you know
liking the beatles hits
you gotta like the [ __ ] deep cuts as
well and i do i like some of his deep
cuts
um this current cut though while totally
watchable
was a little more baffling to me yeah
and a little too long it was like two
hours and 40 minutes
and which at home like you know
i i i'm an eater at heart
and you know in my stuff i'm ruthless
i'll take out and throw out
[ __ ] left and right when it comes to
watching other [ __ ]
especially if i'm watching it at home
where i could pause it go to the
bathroom grab something to eat come back
i'm a lot more forgiving about time but
that being said
i i agree i was like you you could have
done this
this could have been a brilliant 90
minutes you know what i'm saying
given that i didn't know what was going
on i was not pregnant
easy to understand you know
can cinematic [ __ ]
again you know what you're there a
little bit
um i guess
i got [ __ ] connection here man we were
working on that
will wilkins ordered something new that
should make it better
um it seems as if
batman is a pretty good transition if we
wanted one
we we should we might as well transition
now
um there's another warner brothers movie
kids i'm gonna
you know what i gotta close my youtube
window because i'm wondering if that's
[ __ ] with our
main broadcast as well sorry kids i
can't read the comments because
my internet is weak you would imagine
you know the [ __ ] guy who made mall
rats and who lives and
breathes pop culture and [ __ ] and who
hosts
internet shows from his home would have
a better signal but
not at all um you're right uh
speaking of superheroes the superhero
movie came
out man the biggie the one everyone's
been waiting for the one that
history in the making as i said to my
wife as i press play i was like we're
watching history in the making right
here
it will change our business one way or
another because this is a big ass
theatrical release that is opening right
now in theaters it's playing
but also debuted on hbo max now
day and date is not a new thing people
have been doing that for a while
but this is a different kind of day and
date in which
the studio is going to be able to profit
from the theatrical release
but also from their direct to consumer
customer base because they have their
own
app now so it's win-win in their case
because they're like we'll get you the
theater
and we could also get you here on our ch
on our app it'll make you sign up that's
the the thought the theory
so a big deal uh when they decided to
put wonder woman
on hbo max um a big gamble i don't know
financially if it's paid off we saw
their subscriptions
take a jump so maybe uh but really
you know aside from the cinematic
historic cinematic historical
significance of the release
um we had another dc
superhero movie come out
one that's a sequel to one that was
unexpected
although i don't know why unexpected but
an unexpected [ __ ] billion dollar
hit um and so the first one took place
in world war
one which i remember going into the
movie i was like why would you do that
that's the boring war
what the [ __ ] and you know yet they did
a really compelling movie it was
charming as [ __ ] fish out
water story a little bit like splash as
this uh
lady from an exotic uh fantasy land
comes to the real world and stuff in the
middle of the most
one of the most brutal wars ever fought
um we got to see the hero defined we got
to see incredible sequences like her
fighting through no man's land on the
battlefield
um it had a big fuck-off explosion
ending
i want a big explosion kind of ending
where she fought
aries i think that's where things got
weird and washy and
yeah very like there's a floating ring
of garbage in the sky
we gotta stop it yeah kind of standard
um but it was an amazing flick and the
movie made a bunch of money and
everyone's like we're gonna make more of
this
and so patty jenkins who was behind
wonder woman and did a hell of a job
um has been making for the last few
years uh wonder woman
1984 and it debuted on
hbo max um my experience in watching the
movie as previously
mentioned my wife watched it with me and
that never [ __ ] happens when it comes
to
movies like this and she loved it she
was like [ __ ]
applauding [ __ ] cheering she was
doing she was the living version of the
um leonardo dicaprio meme pointing at
the screen the whole time
holding their beer like
so that you know that it's even if she
wasn't in the room i think i would have
had the same experience but
like i enjoyed the fact that she enjoyed
it so much
i found it to be absolutely joyful
start of the movie calls to mind a big
homage to both the
donners superman one and whoever got
credit for superman two but really it
sticked on her as well
um like reminded you of
uh old school
uh chris reeve superman
charming nobody no real hardcore
this [ __ ] is gonna get murdered
this [ __ ] is gonna get branded
in his skin by a [ __ ] bat like
no darkness whatsoever um
as bright as the decade in which the
movie
is set they don't lean into the 80s as
much as they probably could have and
stuff
you know they let you know where you are
and then they kind of just abandon it
just to a large degree um but what it
set up was
uh reverse the story sets up this
reverse
version of the first wonder woman except
this time
um steve trevor played by chris pine
is the fish out of water who's the like
this weird wonderful
modern world which leads to like really
beautiful quiet moments like this guy
who was a pilot if you remember
the first movie sacrifices himself um to
save the day
i can save today but you can save the
world then
so there's this beautiful little moment
where you know here he is in the present
and he sees like just a standard twa
jumbo jet go
over and this kid [ __ ] chris pine is
such a good actor you know who his dad
is
the boss on chips like not even
ponch or john but the boss on chips it
was like get on your bikes and go do
some [ __ ]
this kid is [ __ ] wonderful man and
like he
i'll watch him do anything including my
wife
i wouldn't be insulted in the least i'd
be like he'd do that charmingly
him his delivery him looking at that
plane with a sense of like
wow like communicated in a weird like
way where i'm not a pilot
but i am a person who lives in the
modern world and does take for granted
[ __ ] that i see all the time
and i thought that moment was so
completely well played and it was
practically dialogue free
he also has one of my favorite [ __ ]
moments of the movie when i had to go
back and rewind because it made me laugh
out loud was when they're doing the
fashion show and he goes who would
wear this oh my god he was so good and
when he talked about like
american issue bagged like for the
[ __ ] fanny pack
he was so charming their little story
was absolutely charming
um the uh the uh
maxwell lord storyline um
even that you know villain had
soft edges to it you know i'm not saying
there were no stakes in this movie but
like
you never felt that anyone was in all
that much danger like even from the
opening scene where
you kind of see wonder woman doing her
rounds you know she definitely
there's some jeopardy and whatnot but
you never get the impression that like
people are gonna die you know it just
has that
superman that just started dying until
then then they started dying it's it had
that dick down
or superman feel to it which makes sense
because it was co-written by
jeff johns and he kneels at the altar of
the dick donner superman movies so
you know as a kid who grew up with those
movies i loved that tone
of the beginning of the movie i was like
i'm here for it
when when diana winks at the little girl
in that kurt swann superman way i was
like i'm
so [ __ ] here for this this is
absolutely wonderful
um i'm a kid who grew up watching super
friends so when they announced the
cheetah was going to be the villain i
was like rock on when they announced
that it was going to be
kristen wiig doing i was like oh my god
this is going to be amazing and stuff
um i was delighted uh by cheetah
um in terms of having to balance a
couple
villains which for some reason they
always like to double up on the villains
and sequels and whatnot so you had a
maxwell lord storyline and you also had
a
barbara minerva slash cheetah storyline
that blended fairly well
um never once was i like none of these
motivations make sense like when barbara
went bad as cheetah
kind of makes sense within the scope of
the story as to why she's like
i you know she's got things that she
wants she don't want to lose her [ __ ]
powers
having her get power by way of being
like i want to be like her and not
knowing
that she's wonder woman but getting
those powers anyway i thought was really
cool i thought maxwell lord's backstory
which they eventually get to is
interesting
and new um i thought uh
the romance between steve and and diana
was
wonderful albeit weird because of its
origins we'll get to that in a minute
um you know i didn't mind her being
depowered
um you know getting cut by bullets and
[ __ ] and
and you know i saw a lot of people
online were upset
because you know she's been [ __ ]
training her whole life cheetah's been
cheated for 10 minutes and she can beat
her
what the [ __ ] but you know that wish
fulfillment thing they kind of made it
clear that like one takes from the other
so
as barbara got more powerful wonder
woman got less so like i buy that it
didn't
i didn't bump into that at all i didn't
honestly bump into
much i had a [ __ ] blast of this movie
it's definitely
a flick where you know we were talking
about inception where you understand the
pseudo science
and you're like well all these rules
make sense and stuff
this movie like had something that i
initially you know i had to pause the
movie and turn to my wife and go like
look
i ain't pitching this any complaint and
i'm not [ __ ] on this movie by any
stretch of the imagination
i said but i will say this i will go
with all of these movies you show me
someone with a super power
you show me some [ __ ] flying you show
me some [ __ ]
can like live at the greatest ocean
depths [ __ ]
with a bat wing and gadgets like i will
go with you
everywhere when you
say magic rock
like oddly enough i've got a bias like a
real
bias where i'm like well that can't
happen
and it doesn't seem to apply to all the
other [ __ ] which couldn't happen either
but it's just that one like what do you
mean there's a wishing rock
like you really want to put all your
eggs into the wishing rock
basket that being said
i also remembered the first time i saw
avengers
i bumped into what i called the loki
pokey stick
because you know he's taking over
people's [ __ ] minds and [ __ ] and i
was like
are you kidding me as iron man made a
lot of sense
all these movies make sense you can't
[ __ ] put
some magic [ __ ] mind control stick in
a movie
and expect me to just go along with it
and then of course we found out it
housed an infinity stone later on and
[ __ ] like that
and then i had no problem like later on
i was like oh it's an infinity stone
well of course he could control men's
minds
you didn't name it right then exactly
then the science made sense mark
so the when the wishing rock was
introduced i was like
like dude come on we couldn't have
figured out another way to get all this
[ __ ] going other than a wishing rock and
stuff but then i says to myself
she is a goddess who was formed from
[ __ ] clay
with you know [ __ ] super powers and
and and she fought uh
aries the god of war so like you know
spirituality magic
can totally [ __ ] work and so i was
like you know what i'm gonna
check my bias and go with it and i was
glad i did because i felt like they made
it all
make sense within their magic rock story
like where i was like you know what okay
and and i also had to stop and be like
look every
superhero movie is somebody's first
superhero movie
and wonder woman is like you know a
character that
we've all known for years through tv and
comics and cartoons and stuff
but she's enjoying this whole new
generation
you know people being like this
character is amazing and holy [ __ ]
give us more [ __ ] wonder woman and
stuff including a whole young audience
of little girls who generally you know
maybe don't get
don't aren't so into this [ __ ] and then
you know as we see in the opening scene
of wonder woman alone just like how they
keep cutting to the little girl who's
like wow
you know you got to know your audience
and they happen to know that there's
going to be a lot of little
little kids and particularly little
girls aspiratively
looking up to wonder woman and stuff and
that being said
like i don't i didn't feel like oh this
movie is for children but i'm like well
it's a comic book movie that's like
after you know good 10 years of
dark dc movies they're actually
lightening up and being like hey
our origins we started the superhero
movie with [ __ ] superman the movie
and it was light and fun and you know
yeah there were stakes but
like you know it was about truth justice
and all that good
stuff and whatnot and then you know
there was a an arms race to make the
movies more realistic and whatnot
chris nolan of course making one of the
most realistic comic book movies ever
made and then
marvel being like hold my beer and
finding a way to make
unrealistic [ __ ] nonsense feel
like realistic and whatnot like you know
i mind you i have no problems with
anything that happened
in avengers end game like you know i
can't think of a single thing
and those infinity stones are
essentially magic rocks but i don't bump
into that because i'm like they're
infinity stones
behind it so i don't know i did
i let that go and i was glad i did
because i felt like they balanced their
ship within the magic rock story it's
not what i would have done
but let's be fair mark most of these
movies are not something that i would
have done
so i don't hold that against movies when
they do something that i wouldn't have
done
i base it on what they did do and what
they did do was make that magic rock
story kind of work where i'm like well
good for you guys like i i wouldn't have
gone that route but like
it totally [ __ ] plays and stuff um by
the time
watching uh you know the barbara minerva
uh
cheetah arc come to a conclusion uh with
the big fight
my bar is a lot lower than most people's
and whatnot because i can't make good
cgi anyway and [ __ ] so
whatever anyone could do is always
impressive to me
that being said like i i you know i saw
some people online being like what the
[ __ ] like this
this don't look good at all in terms of
their fight or in terms of the look of
cheetah herself
i come from a different place where i'm
like i used to watch
the super friends every [ __ ] morning
on saturday i'm just
i can't believe there's a [ __ ]
cheetah in a movie
let alone you know [ __ ] they're doing
this version of cheetah
where she's changed her animalistic kind
of appearance or something like that
like
you know i grew up in a world where that
was never going to happen
like you were lucky to get batman and
joker when they felt like giving it to
you
but like wonder woman and wonder woman
versus cheetah
you were never gonna see that [ __ ] in
[ __ ] live action and now we live in
that world so
i'm when cheetah you know pops up on the
screen in full
cheetah regalia and they start going at
it like yeah maybe there are some
moments where the cgi is
a little rubbery and they keep things
very dark and whatnot but
i was never taken out of it i was never
like oh this ain't it i was like you
know what this is great man they're
fighting this is what i wanted i wanted
to see cheetah versus wonder woman
um they started as friends i understand
why they're not now i understand this
one wants to hold on to her power and
stuff and this one just wants the world
to be
a better place and blah blah blah so
you know i i didn't seem to have as much
a problem with the
cheetah effects as others had my one
question though it's one thing to be
like
you know i want to be an apex predator
and i don't know anybody who thinks
cheetahs are an apex predator but
that being said eve i i loved
her whole like i want to be like
something that's never existed before
like
all within the wishing rock storyline it
all tracks
but with all of that if you get you know
your animal
[ __ ] superpowers and you become
unlike anything that's ever been on
earth before do you really
need a tail
and again i i that didn't destroy the
movie for me
but like you know it seemed like the
only reason she'd had a tail in the
movies because
cheetah's got a tail in the comics but
like in the comics
makes absolute sense and as i was
watching the movie i was glad she had a
tail
because i'm like that's comics accurate
but the whole time you know because i
watched the fight
first time and then all the way to the
end of the movie then i went back and
just watched the fight again
and the whole time i watched the fight
the second time i was like the tail is a
real like liability
in any fight let alone a fight with a
goddess
like this so like and but then i was
like that ain't you know that's just me
getting
lost in some thought the one thing i did
bump into
in the movie plot wise mark is
and it's not enough that didn't derail
the movie for me but i sat there going
huh
um spoilers folks obviously we're
spoiling the [ __ ] out of this movie
um because we're reviewing it but
to get steve trevor back
you essentially have to do a
steve martin lily tomlin in all of me
correct according to the
squishy rules of this movie even though
it's a magic rock giving magic wishes
it's true but the whole world was not
seeing chris pine correct
no they were seeing the rando who played
who chris pine took over yes
she has a line where she says all i see
is you and he's in the mirror and you
see
him and the other guy so the whole world
sees that other guy
right the other guy um
as we learned by the end of the movie
didn't seem to know that he was
taken over by chris pine so essentially
chris pines
steve trevor's ghost possesses this man
correct yes or let's say quantum leaps
into this man
what happened on quantum leap where when
sam jumper leaped into a body
where did that [ __ ] go um i
i don't know if they ever explained it
beyond like he's subsuming that person's
personality
for a temporary mission to right the
wrong or to put him back on course or
whatever it was
then i suggest we do a remake of quantum
leap in which we make clear that
whenever sam leaps into somebody
their soul leaps directly to hell
[Laughter]
and it's burning and tortured for that
time
that sam's on the adventure now we know
what sam doing up top
is important like saving kennedy and
[ __ ] like that
but still an innocent soul has to burn
in hell for that hour-long adventure or
however long
sam is in the audience [ __ ] that's a
quantum leap that i think we could all
get beyond
but that being said if she did indeed
uh if they're using the rules of quantum
leap and steve trevor quantum leapt into
this dude's body
this dude had sex with wonder woman
yes at least once at least once that's
what i got out of it i was sitting there
watching the movie going wait wait
she may see chris pine like i'm sure
when my wife [ __ ] me
she sees chris pine as well
but at the end of the day it's me
so you're you're behind the wheel oh
yeah and if somebody was taking pictures
from outside the window
they would not be like oh kevin smith's
wife is [ __ ] chris pine
they'd be like kevin smith's wife
unfortunately is still [ __ ] kevin
smith
so that was a weird moment when i pieced
that together where i'm like
and then she bumps into that dude in the
street
at the end of the movie and doesn't have
the decency to be like
p.s we had sex yes
i raped you a lot i'm sorry are you
you might have chosen me probably would
have i mean look at me but
really you were trapped in quantum leap
hell
and i was having at it with my old
boyfriend in your body it's a
weird notion to introduce into
a movie where again as we said
as depicted in the first scene there's a
little girl going wow
like you know it's it's it's
it's a one thing that i was like what a
strange
concept for some parent to have to
explain to their kid but like wait a
second
who was that other man and they're like
well that man
was the man that that steve trevor
he jumped into his body and so wait
so was she kissing that other man you
know i'd be like kid she was doing a lot
more than [ __ ] kissing
the implication is they [ __ ] did it
hard that night you woke up the next
morning they were in bed together and
[ __ ]
so a weird notion did you notice that as
well when the movie was happening
i kept on wondering in this movie where
there's a magic rock
granting wishes which itself is not
science at all it is
full-blown fantasy fantasy why couldn't
the fantasy
just have steve show up not zombie thief
not like inhabit some other dude's body
possession style
just [ __ ] steve trevor it it does
seem like a
weird moment it's a weird hill to die on
where you're like well we have to make
it understandable believable
and it's like if anything you really
and maybe i'm not seeing it but there is
no practical reason why it had to be
a real dude like you said this is the
magic rock movie like
nobody goes through the bother of having
you to explain why kristen wiig grew a
[ __ ] tale
like it's like she wanted to become a
cheetah she's a cheetah
she wanted steve back unless she had
some convoluted wish of like i wish
steve would take over the body of that
dude i once saw the gym
and then it makes sense but her wish was
i wish steve would come back
unless what they're saying is yes but
there's a price to
these wishes but that's not the price
she pays
yeah in this case the prices some poor
schmuck who had nothing to do with it
he paid the price he's like i'm trapped
in hell
while this fucker's in my body yeah or
i'm trapped in heaven
because i get to have sex a lot with
wonder woman i haven't given consent
so i understand that that's a problem
but this is just weird and i have to
explain to my family where i was
that i've been called for like a week or
two
and they see me on the news next to the
wonder woman like beating up the
president maybe
i don't know i'm sorry anybody watching
the news seeing her running around with
steve trevor
would see that dude and be like there's
that guy with that terrible scarf
and the belt
i lost my girlfriend i lost my house i
lost everything because i'm on tv doing
this
um yeah that was the one thing where i'm
like what a weird note
but other than that i had an absolute
[ __ ] blast
it was it's long like tenant long um but
again
home viewing so what do i give a [ __ ] um
you know was there places they could
have trimmed i mean honestly i'm sure it
could have been shorter but
i'm a guy who could usually be like you
don't need that you don't need that but
there was no one scene that i saw in the
movie where i'm like
you don't need that that could go but
they probably could have tightened it
down
if they really felt the need to but in a
world where it's debuting
predominantly on hbo max like i just
think most people
be like more is better i'll take as much
of that movie as you can give me and
stuff so i don't think that
i don't think the time is a problem for
the audience
at home is maybe that's just me maybe
it's a bias cultural
bias because it's i prefer to be able to
pause and do
things like it'll make the ability to
control the flow of a movie will
improve a movie in some cases you know
where
i think i was a lot more forgiving and
enjoyed tennant more
because i was able to be like i'm gonna
go make it beyond burger and think about
the first 45 minutes
and then i'll come back in and reassess
the movie
i'd be curious whether or not um if this
was the theatrical run time
if once they discovered that it was
going to be on on
on nuclear max that they're like [ __ ]
give the director's cut give them all of
it
i think you i think you're on to
something in as much as that
last scene where it's like it's
christmas
felt very tacked on not like it was
terrible but it felt like
when once they moved out of the summer
like what was supposed to open they were
like we're going to open a christmas
they were like
well the whole movie's set at fourth of
july so let's add a christmas scene at
the end so it feels like they shot that
like way last like a couple months ago
when the move was being made but there's
you may be right where they're like look
in a world where it's debuting here
pull out all the [ __ ] stops like put
it all in don't worry about running time
like we don't have to
squeeze one more screening in on opening
weekend like
go nuts so it was a little bit
uh chunky the other thing i thought was
weird too was
um and these are quibbling little things
um your your girl
walking home in the dark and some
[ __ ] drunk [ __ ] like all right
all right and it goes from like bugging
you to maybe [ __ ] from harassing you to
possibly assaulting you
and then your woman friend comes out of
nowhere and saves you
and you know puts the dude on the ground
and [ __ ] and then
your woman friend is like all right bye
[ __ ] let you keep walking in the dark
like it just felt like at that moment
she might have been like why might as
well walk you home in case
this happens again like you know
literally
down the way or whatever [ __ ] um that
moment felt i bumped into that now
you know weird that i bumped into that
but i didn't bump into the magic wishing
rock as much but i buy
the rules of the magic wishing rock
movie it's fantasy just like
you know like harry potter's [ __ ]
fantasy all that shit's magic wishing
rocket [ __ ]
and so i go on that ride every time and
never [ __ ] but
when you put superheroes into play i'm
like nah not with
magic magic magic's not real
my bias runs into so i enjoyed i thought
patty jenkins
did a wonderful job certainly made a
better wonder woman movie
uh than i ever could um the uh there was
no
i would say like no man's land sequence
moment where it's like holy [ __ ]
remember that
like you know the truck sequence was
that you see in the trailer was great
the opening sequence is wonderful and
warm
uh and the cheetah fight is is uh i i
was very satisfied
um and then the third act like
you know culmination is kind of a
non-fight phil
felt like they got gave you cheetah
because
she it's not like she was gonna fight
maxwell lord although
you know like mark says why not she
could have she could do anything
anything the writers wanted them to do
so i you know
i my kid asked me today like
she was like should i watch one wonder
woman i said [ __ ] yes absolutely you
should
number one what else are you doing
number two
like it's it's wonderful i i felt it was
absolutely joyous um and i you know and
again
the experience of watching it with
somebody who
enjoyed it as much as me if not even
more
um made it even better for me that's me
on wonder woman 1984. now mark i'm sure
you feel the exact same way so we might
as well stop the show
i do take care of you
all i could i'll be honest with you like
you were on my mind the whole time as i
was watching
it because as i watched the movie and i
was so delighted i was like oh mark and
gonna like that
oh mark engle like this oh this part
mark's gonna have a real problem with
this yeah
now i kept on i you know i also watched
it with my family who liked it
quite a bit um a great deal
kind of more than i did and i didn't
hate it um
i just kept on wondering i don't know
where the wonder woman in this wonder
woman movie is
because there's a lot of time that we
spend with maxwell lord
there's a lot of time we spend with
barbara minerva um
and when you get you know gal gadot and
chris pine together like they're lovely
together there's so much great chemistry
i remember listening to this podcast who
was talking about
how similar he found gal gadot and
arnold schwarzenegger
in that neither of them are particularly
good actors
but they are incredibly magnetic as
movie stars like they do the job they're
supposed to do
you know accents be banned you know
they're gorgeous
physical specimens but they embody this
this this this sense of
somehow approachable and somehow god
like on screen
and make whatever they're in just a
little bit better not because they're
great just because of of who they
happen to be and and i felt that a lot
looking at gal gadot
in in this movie but i kept on just kind
of bumping up against
your point the magic rock rules which
are wildly inconsistent for everybody
like max lord kid poor [ __ ] alistair
that sad little like weird orphan who
wishes on that stone like three times
and none of them come true um
and and minerva gets two shots at the
wishing the
magic thing even though you're only
supposed to get one but
and suddenly he decides he wants to be
the witching stone it's not enough to
make his wish on the stone i want to be
it
sure okay what do you get out of it well
i also get to
be the thing that makes the the downside
of your wish become my advantage like
since when yeah that's
that part i didn't quite
under understand the logic of how did he
benefit from other people's wishes
because i think it would be you know if
every wish comes with that
like boomerang slot pack at the end of
it
he could make that flat back be a thing
that benefits him
which is like you want to get this great
i'm going to take all of your oil
you want to get this i'm going to take
all of your whatever you want to get all
these nukes i'm going to take your
weird broadcasting system that lets me
touch people
um and like i need to touch everybody
because i'm dying so i need to take all
their life force
so i can now be healthy again okay
i guess like it all so much this movie
felt like they were making it up as they
went
to the point where the the parts that
are supposed to be consistent
kind of didn't really trap um
and i and i just kept on wondering
what would this movie have been without
maxwell lord
like what if it's actually about these
two women what if it's like about these
two women in the 80s
which was the time where we told women
that you could have it all where it's
the first like
female workforce that's actually going
back into the into the workforce and
actually
i mean whole ad campaigns [ __ ]
looking at flim and
you know look like a pump feel like a
sneaker like you could you could get out
there you could have everything
and so and you have these two women one
of which you know seems to have it all
but is missing
you know her one true love which again
they had sex once
70 years ago he's that good dude
chris pine is an unforgettable lay i
guess
i guess but you know there's also the
world in which
you know and my wife had mentioned it
she was like this is actually kind of
disrespectful
to people who've actually undergone this
kind of traffic loss
because lots of people lose the ones
that they love
and somehow figure out a way to move on
with their lives you know and
find new love and may have new
experiences to build new lives
but this woman who has everything else
can't figure out how in 70 [ __ ] years
to get over the duchy for a week once
whereas like i know my wife died of
cancer and i had to find a way to live
with somebody else oh
car accident i had to like it's it's the
classic superhero
tragedy that nobody else endures like
they do
well it was like spider-man at the end
of spider-man 2 you know where he's just
like you know
she's like i love you peter parker and
he's like i that's awesome but i can't
be with you when [ __ ] walks around
you're like what
why self-impose these rules make no
sense whatsoever
yeah you're right i thought about that
she's like you know she chose
to be solo and celibate and whatnot but
to be fair
she has come from an island of women
that didn't know men and she that was
the first man that she met
and he was charming as [ __ ] and
wonderful
and you know he did sacrifice himself so
it's a high [ __ ] bar
yeah i mean but there's just there's a
way to play that or it's oh i let a life
i did some [ __ ] like i'm not not like
flying this flag for this
one dude like he will always be the one
that got away we always
be the one that's the tragedy you know
just like people who have endured that
kind of loss never forget the time they
had with that person and would
absolutely want to have them back
but it's not their overriding
personality trait
the way it seems to be with diamonds um
i saw somebody online too uh tweeted um
it was a good thought i forget who it
was but it was in like film twitter
i think but it was uh they put up a
picture of
of barbara minerva with the mousy hair
and the glasses and they put up a
picture of
michelle pfeiffer michelle pfeiffer as
cat as selena kyle and catwoman and they
put up a picture
of jamie foxx as
electro with his like greasy hair and
glasses and they were like can hollywood
still
can hollywood please stop with this
[ __ ] trope
about how like having bad hair
and [ __ ] glasses makes you
like one person and then when you come
into your own
you start you know your hair looks great
your glasses go away
you've got cooler clothes the dress gets
shorter
and i really hadn't noticed that like
you know once it was called to my
attention i was like oh my god you're
right it's the same thing all the time
isn't it
it's like i mean but but to be fair
you know the glasses trope
is in the dna of every superhero movie
because
clark kent is mild
mannered in his glasses until he takes
him off and then suddenly he's a god
um so okay i'm gonna i'm gonna pitch you
my version of this movie okay you're
gonna make their movie better don't do
that to daddy jenkins she's having a
great weekend
and she's having a lovely weekend and
and you know i think she deserves to
have a lovely weekend because there is
there are some moments in this movie
that i do like and do respond to
um but i but i think it it
if i if i watch this movie immediately
after the first wonder woman
i kind of start to think what happened
like that was a movie that was kind of
all about
in female empowerment until the last
half hour which is a fun weird studio
maps
but you know it's all about you know the
the lessons of the amazons it's all
about you know keeping your faith and
keeping true who you are
um and it's all about strength without
being cool you know like i think a lot
of what made
diana's wonder woman work is is
there was a softness to the way she just
pummeled things
you know the way she went to the world
that i think some of which you lose a
bit here
it's okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna pitch
all right wait before you pitch
jc give mark the full screen for his
pitch
because i wanna smoke while i listen to
this if he's gonna make the movie better
i've gotta be in the right mind
i could always just blank my screen out
if you need to if you need me to join
there you go look at that
you got full screen sexiness and [ __ ]
ladies and gentlemen give them a
close-up that's what we always used to
do back in the day
give him a [ __ ] single he deserves it
make the movie better
all right so the opening sequence um
which i didn't understand the moral
of like baby diana doing [ __ ] other than
don't cheat which i get it but what if
this is
your baby diana is stronger and faster
than everybody else in this race but
still loses
and maybe the person she loses to is a
digitally de-aged linda carter
like you just make that character an
actual [ __ ] cat which by the way
again spoilers and [ __ ] but that [ __ ]
that was one of the most magical moments
in the movie
was during the credits they should have
found a way to work that into the story
proper because i mean they did and as
much as the setup that where the golden
armor came from but like i would have
had that i would have let that moment
play out like
in the movie not in the credits because
it was wonderful
go ahead so you get beads linda carter
who wins the race
um you know the moral there is that
power doesn't make one great
um the greatness comes out with being
the fastest or the strongest but it
becomes
the greatness is in what you do with it
um
you wipe the movie of almost every trace
of maxwell lord i believe if you have to
have him he's a these are kind of a low
level
like tertiary bad guy but whatever you
still have
all of the the barbara minner the diana
bonding but you give more time to the
fact that this is how
uh diana's lived her life this is this
is the
the um even though the candle she's had
lit for steve
forever like there's still other parts
to it here's here's how i've spent
70 years with what i've been doing with
myself and i found kind of empty
in the same way that barbara has found
her life empty and that you know
she's been you know trying to to make a
name for herself and she's got this
really good job at smithsonian but
you know nobody notices her nobody cares
for her
ultimately nobody loves her um and so
when barbara makes her wish it's not to
be like diana
it's literally to be diana so that when
diana eventually starts experiencing
power loss
it's because the power is going from her
to barbara
that barbara is going to become an
amazon she's going to have all that
power and strength
but instead like it's it's a greedy dark
amazon and she's your [ __ ] big bad
like barbara
nerve is the big bad of the movie
because you know could the world
actually stand against
a wonder woman who wasn't good and kind
like no
not at all you know if you want to have
somebody going to the white house and
bring reagan to his knees
it should be [ __ ] barbara minerva not
maxwell lord
and not through wish granting but
through sheer power like make him kneel
before minerva but let's let's steal
that bit from the from the donovers
you know and and and that's your
trajectory even though
diana gets what she wants by getting to
have steve cover back
that was her wish and that can also play
you know
she's and again it's it's pure donner
she's getting less powerful by having
what she wants with
with steve trevor as barbara gets more
powerful
and begins to just [ __ ] dominate um
and then you of course you realize that
diana is going to need to at some point
deal with nerva and then
you show that scene that you were just
asking for karen where gal gadot
as [ __ ] diana go to linda carter
as whatever her partner's name was an
artesia artemis whatever it was
um who'd now older who'd been in man's
world perhaps for longer
than than diane has ever been and she
says she needs
the i need the armor like i don't my
power is gone i can't stand i need the
armor to protect me
and ultimately that scene is where linda
carter reminds [ __ ] wonder woman what
being one woman is all about
which is you were bred from warriors who
were trained at the feet of the finest
warriors the world has ever
known power doesn't make you great so in
the third act [ __ ] diana has to face
her
powerless which is why of course you
need the [ __ ] armor relying on the
skill in this
martian part to win and she finally
forces barbara to renounce her wish
you wanted to be loved and now you're
feared you need to let it go
um but that's only half of this thing
and the only people who [ __ ] get
wishes in here are barbara and diana
like we don't need the world
getting their wishes granted you need
your protagonist
so barbara announces her wish um of the
power
but it's not the end the end is diana
needs to follow suit
so the last the big last sequence not
the kickoff of your third act but the
culmination of your third act
is diana needs to say divided steve she
realizes that that he's the one that's
keeping
you know barbara is still overpowered
and so she needs to let go of her old
love to bring the world back to normal
and if you have to have max lord then
he's a low level schmuck doing like oil
scheme crimes
and maybe he cottons up to barbara
because she knows ancient [ __ ] about an
everlasting oil well tied to an artifact
or whatever
and they're a team until barbara gets
too powerful and she kills him which
marks her
descent into the dark side but like
i kept on wondering and wanting this
movie to be about what those two women
want
and how their desires are somewhat
misguided by
grief and fear and how they learn that
neither of those things are necessarily
bad they're part of being human
but they need to be tempered by in
diana's case hope
and by in in barbara's case love
that's my pitch bring me back
i want to be back on the show
oh well um
that's not covet that's weird
in chat mark number one everyone was
really delighted
that you got to speak uninterrupted
there was a lot of like oh my god he's
letting him
talk and then they were like he's not
even on screen and he keeps interrupting
and that's when i jumped out all
together um
you had you went from uh
people being like yeah mark do it to
people being like
[ __ ] this sucks to people being like
this is much cleaner and [ __ ] better
i watched
the story capture the audience and
captivate them as it went on and stuff
well done
thank you um i don't do that i never do
that i never sit there and be
like here's how i would make this movie
differently i'm always just like all
right well i couldn't do that so
we're good yeah i mean because i didn't
want to you know i i
i've decided as of not even that late
but i don't want to just [ __ ] on things
like you're shooting on it doesn't help
anybody
the real cobra burnout says mark just
wrote a better movie in real time
correctly wb take notes
all of these things are like doctor
say again all of these things feel like
constructive exercises which is you know
like okay if you didn't if you didn't
like it if it didn't work for you why
didn't it work for you
and for me it didn't work for me because
you know the the protagonist and the
antagonist were not necessarily tied
together in the way you wanted them to
be
and you know maxwell lord has nothing to
do with diana
like he's not her bad guy in a way he's
he's minerva
she doesn't actually points out she's
like i don't even have a television
so yeah the dude was yeah don't know who
you are like i guess you're doing bad
things but
it's not about me in any real way and so
figuring out a way
to make it about who diana is and what
diana means to other people
specifically what she means to barbara
and you can still have that opening
scene in the mall when you see this
little girl and it's all about
you know the weirdness of of wonder
woman trying to maintain her secrecy
seems to be at odds with her wanting to
be symbol
for young women uh so she'll happily
take the one at a time as opposed to the
the you know millions of times by being
public
but even still realizing that what i
mean to people matters
and and barbara has taken that the wrong
way
she's seen jealousy and envy in a place
where i was just hoping for inspiration
and i need to realize that if i don't
give enough to these people
they will take the wrong message from my
presence and maybe that's
inspires her to go public maybe that is
her i am iron man moment
i was kind of um i love the moment in
the fight when you know
again spoilers and if you're still here
and you haven't seen
her apology but we're in there fighting
and she's like you know barbara you got
to renounce your wish
and kristen wigg's like never i was like
that's [ __ ] cheetah man so i was like
this would be a badass
like she's gonna she's like i'd rat from
hell's heart i stab at thee and [ __ ]
but then the implication at the end is
that she did make
she did renounce her wish so she does
she was so when she said never she
wasn't
she she was lying bad guys lie
um no i yeah i i
um i enjoyed the [ __ ] out of myself i
could see myself watching this movie
again
um i got a lot out of it a good time
and my kid asked me
she goes um did you like it more than
aquaman
and i said i i think i liked it
differently than i liked
aquaman like this was a
much sweeter movie um
you know and there's nothing i'm not
saying aquaman is an action movie and
there's
you got a few sweet moments but it's
like a driving
action flick very packed to the [ __ ]
gills epic
and um this like oddly enough felt
more quieter do you am i saying it wrong
do you agree i mean
it's quieter than aquaman only because
every movie is quieter than aquaman
because i guess yeah like aquaman had
like
96 movies happening in it and so
this one had one and maybe that's why it
fell
let me ask you this and this is not a
complaint either but i'm just
curious why 1984 did
did they ben did was there anything at
all that kept them
from doing this exact same story in the
year 2020
um i mean i i suppose they're trying to
play
on the it's such a weird
choice to be temporarily fixed to the
80s and then do nothing with the 80s
there's like 380 songs on the soundtrack
i'm like
what the and that was the the weird
thing it was like well there was nothing
inherently like oh
what happened like what was the one uh
x-men movie they did
first class where the cuban missile
crisis was happening where you're like
all right
now i know why they chose this era so
there was no 80s moment like you know
and i don't know what a
seminal like you know the shooting of
reagan or the [ __ ] challenger or
something that like
made you go oh of course that's why it
had to be
yeah if it's gonna be all about oil
which it seemed to be
why not do the 70s where there was
actually like an opec oil crisis when
like there were gas lines running from
miles down the street
and you know the hostage crisis is
overseas around oil tankers like all of
that [ __ ] that was happening
i feel like it wanted to be about greed
you know wanted to be about how max lord
wanted
just wanted more to have more and how
barbara minerva wanted to have more
everybody wanted everybody wanted what
they wanted in the 80s is the
the decade of greed and excess i guess
that's the point
in but never in chapter they've got
other theories blaise melandra said i
think the cold war
and threat of nuclear war with russia
was the reasoning
behind the setting in the 80s and jose
alves also said cold war but
i mean unless i'm forgetting something
like i remember at the end
you know the president was like i wish
for more nukes which was like what
why wouldn't you wish for world peace or
some such [ __ ] but regardless
um and then there was an escalation but
that
why not they you could literally do that
same story now it's not like
we're in the middle of a [ __ ] cold
war aren't we like
aren't russians the bad guys yet again
and have been for the last
four [ __ ] years and and like so it
feels like
you didn't have to go back to the 80s to
tell the story
you could have told the same story here
yeah maybe
maybe it would have been too long for
steve trevor to come back but like
how long is too long it's been [ __ ]
65 years since it comes back in this
version of the story
so you know i just can't see a reason
why they did 1984. and i'm not saying
they shouldn't have but like i i
i guess they were just like why not like
why not pick that up
i mean and especially when we've been
confronted by
and in great cases delighted by things
like stranger things
which goes hard into being about the 80s
and being the life that it lives in the
80s and the town of the 80s and
the maul and stranger things was a way
more convincing maul than you get here
you know 80s nostalgia you know is is a
real
engine when it's sort of deployed right
and like i'm to your point like again
the president says i want more nukes and
then becomes a big nuclear explanation
that nobody really cares about or does
anything about
you know max lord doesn't do it or
foment it really
wonder woman doesn't stop it it's not
like you know she's trying it's not the
superman thing where she's trying to
stop max lord stop cheetah stop and
think from flying
stop people from dying like she's not
overwhelmed by
all of these tasks she's gotta you gotta
solve
it's just background color which is
weird
pika snipe and chat says you write it in
84
so you don't have to worry about the
rest of the justice league
in a global crisis it was a wonder woman
story duh
lol i hadn't thought about that that's
true you wouldn't set it now
because then people be like where's
aquaman where's cyborg where's batman
so fair enough that's why you don't set
it post justice league
um that being said
still 1984 like there was no
would have been 96 could have been 73
why not you know what i'm saying like
wonder woman 99
like yeah i mean unless they're planning
on the sequel being
you know one woman 96 or whatever talk
about her flying
i loved it you um i was agnostic on it
you know like i i i didn't mind the
flying as much as i reminded her
swinging everywhere on her lasso
like guys that's new i got a spider-man
movie i got lots of spider-man movies
i noticed that like it was her not
during the olympiad or whatever on
the obscura but at one point she was
doing something and i was like that's
literally web slinging right there
um but i enjoyed the you know
the riding the lightning and [ __ ] like
that or the [ __ ] lassoing the missile
was dope
but just the notion of oh i'm going to
try
flying you know because she does in the
comics
um yeah which you know she does and she
didn't like i think flying for her
came and went over the course of based
on who whoever was writing it
yeah like the post 52 wonder woman could
totally fly but before then it was a
little bit like hulky
where she's like she jumped real high
and then just figured out how to ride
the wind and then that carried over
she used her invisible jet in the
cartoons uh speaking of which
the invisible jet moment did that melt
your heart a little or or
i i loved the like the sequence of it
is very like you know can you read my
mind which i kind of dug
but the did she just steal a jet
like why is she stealing a jet and are
they
flying to cairo and can he fly in chat
and do they have enough fuel to get to
cairo
it's invisible but it has gas though
right like
it was a lot of weirdness leading up to
a moment that i really liked
it's so weird i should not be in this
business because i should be in the
audience that's where i came from and
it's where i
we're not for sheer [ __ ] luck and
timing i'd still be sitting in the
audience
because to me i was you know the moment
there
she was like i've been you know my
father could
shielded themskera from the world and
i've been trying to
i think i can make this invisible or
however they set it up i was just like
yes here comes the invisible jet fan
service [ __ ] like i was
i was swept away never once was i like
i just you know i was i just bought in
whole hog and [ __ ]
but what was the thing that you bumped
into you're like why is he stealing a
[ __ ] play how come she stole a plane
yeah it's like they go from we can't buy
you a ticket for an actual plane
because you don't have a license so
instead i will somehow
steal a jet that's just in the backyard
here
because you know i was like but really
that's
that that's a thing that just happens
sure okay
the caretaker uh on chat
said i bet kevin cried when the jet
turned invisible
i did i cried when the jet turned
invisible
i cried in the opening ceremony i
thought that was really kind of
beautiful i cried
in the mall when she [ __ ] appears for
the first time like
all that goofy saving the day [ __ ] which
wasn't even like you know think about
this and i'm not
this ain't me [ __ ] on anything one
one iota but
remember in justice league like the
first appearance of wonder woman is like
this crazy british guy who's like my
bombs not gonna go off
so i'm gonna shoot all these children in
the [ __ ] face
and you know she shows up and stops them
into like that is
[ __ ] harrowing like really harrowing
and [ __ ]
nothing in this movie particularly in
the first like 15 minutes
was very harrowing you know maybe the
guy
grabbing the girl and holding her over
the railing
was a little bit hairy that was as
intense as it [ __ ] got and [ __ ]
but like you know wonder woman saves
were were charming
you know and like and straight out of
the you know
dick don or superman whereas and i no
disrespect to wonder woman's
you know [ __ ] saving the day and her
first scene in in justice league i guess
it was but like
it was pretty it was insanely brutal
where you're like
this guy's gonna [ __ ] kill these kids
like at one point he was gonna shoot the
kids before the bomb went off and you're
like
you're all in the same room you're all
gonna die but yet you wanna shoot these
little girls in the face what is your
feet
shoot the kid um so i did appreciate
that i cried like when she
you know [ __ ] say i cried when the
little girl was like wow
because that's how i still feel when i
watch
this [ __ ] even at age 50 like
it still captures my heart my
imagination and then i do
think about and i you know i don't know
if i ever would have thought about this
without being prompted but i've been a
married man for over 20 years
and my wife is a pretty hardcore
feminist so
like her you know for years she's been
going like
like you know you don't understand she's
going when you were a kid
you had everybody superman [ __ ]
batman [ __ ]
you know spider-man list goes on she's
like
we had nobody we i was a girl and girls
were always being rescued she's like and
then we saw star wars and i saw a girl
who was getting rescued but she had a
[ __ ] gun and she was shooting people
so she's like i'm all for any movie
where you know they [ __ ] let the girl
shine because i didn't see that when i
was a kid so when we saw wonder woman in
the theater for the first time
that whole opening sequence where you
know they're doing the
what the bat what what opens that movie
it's the it was just the training staff
on
training where you're seeing the or and
also the when the army shows up on the
beach and all of a sudden they start
swooping down and fighting and [ __ ]
like she was i looked over my wife was
crying her eyes out and
like that's i'm like that's my job like
what are you crying
and she was like like i my whole life
i wanted to see a movie like this where
i could look up
and see myself see a girl like doing the
heroic things being the lead and stuff
so when like wonder woman
shows up in the mall and she comes over
the [ __ ] railing and you see her full
body reveal shot for the splash page
image
and they push in on the little girl
who's like wow
like that [ __ ] makes my heart soar
because i know there's a bunch of cats
out there who are viewing the movie
in that way like this is somebody's
first
superhero movie and they're getting bit
by the [ __ ] bug
right now and going like wow and for
that exact reason if they're looking up
and seeing a representation
of themselves like a female as opposed
to just
another guy so moments like that made me
cry the uh
like i'll be honest when she fought
cheetah i was in tears because i'm like
i can't believe i've lived
so [ __ ] long that i'm seeing this
happen in real life somebody [ __ ] put
cheetah versus wonder woman
in a [ __ ] movie and wonder woman's
wearing the golden armor and i you know
i know i saw
some some cats on twitter like really
[ __ ] on that cheetah fight but
like i thought it was [ __ ] dope man
wings the gold
wonder woman robes herself and shrouds
herself in the wings
and then cheat is just like bam bam
bitman at one point like wedges them
open and [ __ ] like that
i thought that looked so badass and
threatening but it did make me go
like how much is that how good is this
[ __ ] armor
storm super good like honestly if this
was the armor that this one woman used
to defend an army of the 300 like
[ __ ]
you know and suddenly just pieces of
raftering off i'm like either cheetah is
way overpowered
or this armor is kind of like you know
the [ __ ] awning you pull down in
front of a store
and if you hit it enough it's gonna go
away like is it mythical or is it not
craig chat said the whole fight was on
the rope
he's actually right it was kind of a
cirque du soleil fight
lots of swinging lots of swinging lots
of because that's what cats do i guess
yeah i kept wondering i mean my my
biggest structural problem with the
movie i guess
is egypt which is
why like why are we in egypt
like it's because max lord wants to go
to egypt to get some [ __ ] sultan he
saw in the copy uh
some prince and then on the cover of a
magazine to get whatever that dude's
stuff is but wonder woman doesn't care
about egypt really
you know so she follows him there and
you get the big tank fight which is kind
of cool
but then they don't catch the bad guy
and they just have to go home
somehow like it's the weirdest
boondoggle that gets you nothing
story-wise or character-wise other than
here's the first time maxwell lord kind
of over exceeds his power
and erects walls and the sinai or
whatever the [ __ ] that is
but it it struck me a lot as the the
kanto bite sequence we're like
why am i on this casino planet how is
this a good idea
what does this have to say about my hero
and what she wants
not very much of anything and then
somehow
they have to get back from cairo to meet
barbara minerva
next to a record store and
somehow they do this with an invisible
jet if she couldn't find a mug that was
invisible she's also
not supposed to find the jet that she
misplaced that now has enough gas to fly
back to the states like it
it all becomes this weird logical
[ __ ]
like aruba that you start eating itself
and that's about when i started to just
give up on logic in this movie just like
all right it's just gonna do what it
does
i guess sure got a magic rock man you
can't argue with the magic rock
chris sant in the chat says and this
hadn't even occurred to me he goes like
why is it a cat
against a bird laughing my ass off i
guess he's right she was wearing golden
eagle armor so she's a bird and
cheetah's a cat so it was literally
sylvester versus tweedy
for a third act battle um let me see
there's another one here
uh the coffins said i felt wonder woman
84 would have been better
as a mini series look
i'll take mini series on all this [ __ ]
man give me 10 episodes or
eight episodes i'd prefer that to the
two hour movie of this stuff
any old day but uh an interesting
thought i hadn't thought about that
um we're probably going to start seeing
you know and with the success of
mandalorian
and now with the foregone conclusion
success of juan division
and and uh and falcon and the winter
soldier
like we're going to start seeing some
long-form
comic book storytelling i mean i know
the people that have enjoyed uh
agents of shield and whatnot and and all
the folks who watch the netflix
shows and the hulu shows i guess we've
been suing it for a while and it's not
like there's anything new
i was like disney's going to redefine it
but they're going to redefine it with
quality it looks like they're spending
tons of money on their series man
yeah i mean it'll be the first time we
get it
where the storytelling is happening in
two places at the same time
where it's you will get some of it in
the movies and then you will get some of
it on tv
and if you want to know what's going on
you need to go both places for it
you know the agents of shield while the
tangentially tied into the mcu
never was essential to the mcu same
thing with the netflix shows
you know you could watch all of them and
they would bear very little impact
on what happened in the movies and it
only barely references remember that
thing that happened in new york again
that sucked right
like and that's kind of it um but i
think that now
you won't be able to understand the
things that happen
in i don't know you know
the the multiverse of madness unless you
saw
one division true
crucial storytelling yeah um
ben wellington said something that i i
did notice when she rolled with those
kids
remember she rescued the kids he said
when she rolled with those kids dummies
they slam their heads on the pavement so
hard they she did like
i did notice that she rescued those kids
and then she lost the lasso or whatever
[ __ ] let go
and then she hit so [ __ ] hard
i thought they were gonna do a story
line where she's like oh my god these
children
died because of me because they hit so
[ __ ] hard man but then
they cut to the shot of like they're
okay yeah
like i i there was a lot of spectacle in
this movie but a lot of it felt very
empty
to me because a lot of it didn't feature
your main characters
you know like all of that [ __ ] that's
happening in the world is not
because of or being helped by anybody
that you're
really interested in um you know so your
big climactic fight is two people on a
satellite dish tower you know and then a
conversation
um inside a swirly wendy thing
you know and i dug that the conversation
i dug that the resolution was not i'm
going to punch max lord until he dies
but i'm going to try and convince the
world to rescind their wishes
um it's like you know i dig that i dig
that as as one woman's
solution which is not is to greet the
world with love and not with hate
with you know an open hand and not a
closed fist like i dug that
but i wish that the maybe the minerva
fight
was bigger so the spectacle was actually
somewhat more spectacular
in chattel mark jones said uh so linda
carter was also the president and
supergirl
alternate earth i guess yeah man those
are cw shows
these movies don't take place in the cw
verse although after the flash movie it
sounds like
we'll see a multiverse come together um
then there's this point here
from les ross says i love reading men
debate about how
one women character should be based on
their clear experience of what it's like
true it's true i you know i i don't we
certainly have no
room to say what a real woman would act
like visa versus the
these fictional women but
i don't i don't think you have to be a a
woman to
you know say like well shouldn't
couldn't she
be like i don't know i didn't think we
were being
couldn't diana have made the decision
that steve needed to go away
and not steve like isn't it kind of
better for your hero if she makes the
big sacrificial choice
of like i can't have you anymore
daniel herrera points out very quickly
in the chat he goes a man created wonder
woman
it's true man i saw his name big and
wild on the screen william moulton
marsh and there's what's that movie
called that they did
like the the professor dr martin's women
or something like that
yeah professor marston and the women or
something um
it tells the story of where the wonder
woman's secret origin came from and
stuff
fascinating this was a dude involved in
an open relationship with two women
yes and all about that bondage life [ __ ]
yeah i should have called it wonder man
how the [ __ ] he pulled that off um
yeah man it's uh it's totally worth uh
giving your time to i feel okay uh
pretty much pointless says my wife was
pissed
that wonder woman was so stuck on steve
on needing steve she didn't seem to need
him she just likes him a lot you know it
makes her happy and [ __ ]
but i didn't you know it wasn't like
steve without you we can't do this
like he seems like the ultimate
boyfriend and as much as he's like you
know she's got this and when she needs
help i'll jump in
but he's not like you know stand behind
me diana or any of that [ __ ]
she's like she's the she's the powerful
one yeah she's the alpha in this
relationship
and and i i like him being the damsel in
distress
i uh i was wondering if they spent all
the
soundtrack budget on the snyder cut
which is why we didn't get
one single needle drop 80s pop song in
this like the
top one we got frankie goes to hollywood
i think we'll
relax it wasn't relaxed though was it it
was um
i thought it was when it's the the
montage the trying unclosed montage
no the the song the frankie song is when
they're walking into the gala and
gal gadot has that white dress on with
the slit
and then kristen wiig is right behind
her and that was a
a remix of a frankie goes to hollywood's
song
somebody says rio by duran duran was in
there i didn't remember hearing that at
all
i just you know mark mentioned welcome
to the pleasure dome was the song that
they used
you know something stranger things did
so well
was you know the soundtrack to make you
feel like it was the 80s this
just felt like they forgot they spent
that money on the
five minutes of snyder and uh they ran
out
are you don't do hungry like the wolf
when cheetah
is around like how you don't do two
tribes go to war
when they're fighting like love is a
[ __ ] battlefield it's just sitting
there waiting for you
like ways to use that music to help tell
that story
and help you sell that we're in the 80s
and the 80s with so much about
how music had changed and how that the
reflective of the culture
it feels like like either an oversight
or somehow they ran out of money
which i don't believe they did and uh
the song that was in the trailer whether
they use
blue monday um
how does it feel that wasn't even in the
movie at all
i mean it was like so amazing in the
trailer but that song wasn't yeah it's
crazy they really didn't lean into the
80s of it
at all music wise i mean the you know
first scene people had some like
bright clothing on but even the outfit
that he's in the whole movie
and also like were fanny packs the 80s
oh yes it must have been late 80s
because i remember
when fanny packs were popular and i
wouldn't have remembered it until
with a gun in my head i would have said
like early 90s i think
and i remember being part of like you
know breaking
through some kids are cooling around
with [ __ ] fanny packs like i i
remember that as a thing
but never quite you know
maybe not quite that early um did you
you know what i did like too was the um
you know i'm a [ __ ] comic book nerd
so like
simon stag being one of the characters i
was like
simon's stack stag industries like he'll
be responsible later on for the
elemental man and [ __ ] like that um
they're uh the cameo by
etta candy old asset of candy
um the one liberating of the camp
shot of world war ii they glossed over
world war
ii completely right first movies world
war one
and here it's a quick picture of like
yeah she [ __ ] freed some camps and
stuff
like they showed you her life and they
showed you like
everyone getting older and stuff i
thought that was really
nice yeah
i just i i i just i would like to say i
left this movie but it was just my house
i turned it off
um just feeling that i wanted more
ironically for a movie that's so much
about
more um i just wanted it to dig a bit
deeper into these characters and
and and focus and focus it a little bit
more
you know i think that patty jenkins is a
very gifted director
um and i think that that you know kind
of left to her own devices
um she can deliver some amazing stuff
but i just it didn't feel like the
script
um had the foundations that you needed
to be able to make this your worthy
follow-up
to what a wonder woman was like i never
had that feeling that i felt
on either thermoskira in the beginning
or no man's land
in that movie and i get that it's hard
to replicate that kind of
emotional um rate because much of that
was about it being the first time you'd
ever seen it
you know and so you can't can't put
lightning in a bottle twice
but it didn't even feel like it tried
that hard
um to do that to give you those moments
that you could actually just stand up
and cheer
um and that's that's kind of what i was
i was missing i was missing that stuff
um bald ball bulldozer in chat goes i
wanted
less wishing rock but somehow more
wishing rock
like fight the god who is actually
behind it i mean there's a
and thought of that like there's a good
there's a good story right there yeah
there's a lot of like who is it is it a
trickster is it a good guy it's like
well let's find out
i was going to say my favorite comment
in chat was jose
alves said pedro pascal is the best
and worst father of the year 2020.
that isn't great who said that great
jose jose alves
best father mando worst father wonder
woman
this is so damn true yeah the poor kid
um that felt very jeff john's to me the
the
sun and the kids storyline that felt
like it was plucked out of
shazam or something like that um and
again
i appreciated that it was there because
you know
we we talk about this [ __ ] you know and
analyze it
and what it means to us but these movies
primarily are for a much younger
audience than
us and so it's nice to see them reflect
that audience
like in the story not just as like
here's a little kid let's hang her over
the [ __ ] railing of the mall
but like you know he's got a son and the
son
should be something of a factor and you
know
was kinda ish but
but of course there's kids in the movie
like it makes sense and that made me
happy i'm like that's
that's kind of good eric mai said what
do i think david callahan
brought to the script because there's
three screenwriters it's
patty and jeff johns and that
third guy i figured he's the dude who
came into the polish right before they
went to draft or something
right before they went to to shoot yeah
either that or he was the first guy on
me
who was like yeah i'll his name would be
up top if he's last in line then he's
last to touch it
did i just school you on [ __ ]
writer's guild did you just go silent
because i was like
no mark that's not how you say maybe
but then decided not to because
i've never done arbitration so i don't
know the innards of those were so
asked and answered thank you councilman
um
so uh ball bulldozer said can't wait for
the sideshow collectibles 400
wishing rock you can easily replicate
that [ __ ] thing
yeah which will cost more than they say
it costs in the movie
ricky ricky ray says terrible give me my
podcast money back
i think that's his review of our show um
here's your free money back ricky in
fact here's a free million dollars on
top of it
sorry we couldn't satisfy you [ __ ] off
um somebody also said did i not
see linda carter's eyes in
in the when uh the flashback story was
being told
what was her character's name astra or
aristra or something like that
cartesian artesia they showed her and at
one point they showed like a close-up of
her eyes
and she looked like you could say if you
know linda carter from tv not like if
you know her in real life
although i do but if you know her at all
like you could see your eyes and i in
that moment i was like holy [ __ ]
so i had a feeling that there was going
to be some linda carter action coming
that moment abs hysteria her name was
that moment made me absolutely
[ __ ] cry i thought that was so
beautiful
the only way you could have improved
that is if you put gal in the scene with
her but then there'd be a lot of
explaining to do
i thought it was just absolutely
wonderful like my only ask would have
been like move that into the body of the
real story i know they want to end it on
the
articular hero and stuff but like that
was so pretty you could have put
that right before the credits man like
and let's be honest
a lot of us going to see this movie for
us
wonder woman was linda carter so
naturally we would be
super receptive to it and it seems like
the internet has been i was happy for
she was uh she seemed like she
tweeted or instagrammed about it i read
her post somewhere
linda carter and she was so [ __ ]
delighted
you know to be involved and they pulled
it off and stuff like that it was really
sweet
um well there it is man we talked about
both brand new warner brothers movies um
and we talked about the tenant
we talked about wonder woman in 1984. uh
go see these movies in your home or
in a theater if you're one of those
lucky [ __ ] places where you can get
out
or if you're like jc [ __ ] scum and
villainy rich you can just rent your own
private
movie theater and stuff um
yes check these movies out uh for
yourself
man if you haven't already but something
tells me if you've been watching this
you've definitely got some skin in the
game uh my hat goes off
to patty jenkins um i couldn't have done
it
i think she did a wonderful job and uh
next up is what rogue squadron for her
it is like unless there's something in
between but
you know she got a thing for planes and
jets
well she talked about them dad was a
pilot right or something yeah dad was a
pilot
um who i think you know passed
um in in action which i think she
mentioned that that
you know she lost him too young um so
yeah there's definitely a part of her
that's very much about telling me
stories about fly boys
i remember i saw her i don't know if it
was not last year but maybe
the year before at sundance when i was
interviewing people at sundance for imdb
um i forget what she was there for but
uh i got to talk to her for
a few minutes and uh she's so lovely
really sweet person
but i of course i was just like i gotta
know
cheetah does is it an outfit
or is it like does she go feral
and she's like both and i said do you
put her in that [ __ ] outfit from the
super friends with the little ears on
him
and she goes we don't do that outfit but
no there's she goes there is an outfit
and then
and then she goes funeral and stuff um
and damn skippy if she wasn't she was
telling the truth
there was a cheetah like and you could
have done a version of that movie where
you know kristen wiig just wore that
outfit and that was that
and was strong and maybe in the third
act
she put on the little ears and that's it
but in the comics
you know they've done cheetahs gone full
[ __ ] feral
human cat hybrids so naturally
you're making a movie this is the
perfect venue for that kind of [ __ ]
like here's a cat person you ever wanted
to see what a cat people look like i was
like yeah
natasha kinski showed us years ago i
remember
i was kind of hoping that when she
decided she wanted to be an apex
predator
the next time we saw her she had like
[ __ ] shark fins another shark
it's like oh apex yeah no sharks totally
you know lions maybe
[ __ ] bald eagle uh yeah it's
i mean don't lions eat cheetahs
yeah cheetahs are not the top of their
food no like they get hunted by other
like
man eating or not manny but like [ __ ]
carnivores like
lions i forget who else but cheetahs
aren't like oh man
first there's a cheetah and then there's
everything [ __ ] up
she should've been working kill her
whale it would have been amazing if she
was like i
i want to be like four down from an
apex predator
what's that what's like a really good
predator like look
i ain't shooting for the stars i'm gonna
keep it realistic because even though
this is magic wishing rock
and keep [ __ ] real so i don't want to be
king of the jungle i want to be like
vi count of the jungle i want to be like
you down here i want to be scary to any
human
but like i want there to be four other
animals who are not scared of me at all
uh would you like to be a cheetah yeah
[ __ ] yeah that's
there it is um wow wow man well we
waited for a long time now we know what
wonder woman 1984
is all about if you don't know what it's
all about go watch it that's on hbo max
if you don't have hbo max subscribe
because
they're going to give us the goods for
the next [ __ ] few months man
now you know what movie i'm really hyped
to see now as there's been reports that
maybe dune might
not be going to hbo max and maybe
godzilla as well
legendary is putting up their lawsuit or
whatever
but the saints of newark the [ __ ]
sopranos prequel
that's right in that bunch and now i'm
just like give me that man because i
just watched
[ __ ] sopranos all the way through now
give me that [ __ ] dicky maltesanto
prequel man so yeah if you don't have
hbo max get yourself some of that hbo
max boy they got a lot of cool [ __ ]
coming and whatnot and wonder woman 1984
you can only watch it there for a month
and then yeah so
enjoy a tenant available anywhere where
you can buy a [ __ ] movie or
rent a movie or something like that not
on a streamer yet
in its transactional window totally
worth seeing
chris nolan patty jenkins two of the
greatest directors
at their game and whatnot and uh and uh
this [ __ ] in a world where we're all
home and you got that to watch why the
[ __ ] are you watching this
go watch it i know i'm gonna shut us
down and go watch seoul
on disney are you watching so
the new picture oh yes that's right
somebody in chat was like are they going
to talk about seoul
i almost watched it today but instead i
finished up the sopranos so
yeah next week we'll be able to talk
about seoul
yeah you didn't watch it yet not yet not
yet
too much of christmas was uh was the the
the revelatory celebrations of what's
that box
what's in that box what's in that box
and so we didn't have time
for three movies must be nice to have
family [ __ ]
[Laughter]
god bless us everyone you know what i
don't need that
kid and my in-laws because i got this
family right here
the batman beyond family a family of fat
folks uh did you like the show tonight
ladies and gentlemen
today uh if you did it's because that
guy
over there man uh the one who uh
wrote you a a a completely different
wonder woman story
in real time i'm sure that made everyone
at warner brothers real happy they're
like yeah thanks
you spent years and millions of dollars
but go ahead
make it better sure we'll give you
10 minutes um give it up
uh for the man without whom there is no
fat man beyond give it up for mr mark
bernard
thank you sir uh thank you to jc for
making room
for us and his uh brand new baby family
christmas and whatnot um jc your
thoughts on
ww84 the 83rd
sequel to wonder woman um i think i kept
ex watching the movie hoping to see what
you and mark
wrote year last year when they announced
chris pine and
martian manhunter and all that and i
didn't get any of that so i was
disappointed the entire time waiting to
see the movie you guys wrote last year
who was that was that mark that came up
with the idea of having to be marching
man hunter
yeah man that would have been [ __ ]
crazy satisfying
i forgot about that oh [ __ ] yeah
see now that you could have done that
but i'm with mark
you literally since it's a magic wishing
rock there needed to be
no logic there it didn't have to be some
man
possessed it literally just could have
been like hey i'm back
yeah and then when she wishes him away
he just vanishes [ __ ]
into thin air like a like a force ghost
i'm with you on that um how about
tennant did you see 10 at jc or no
i i can't watch a movie
like i feel like christopher nolan has
become orson welles
it's like you named your guy protagonist
you're the savior of cinema like there's
just
only so much pompous i can take before i
can't watch anymore
jc's got one pompous director he deals
with every week
enough you can't [ __ ] handle smith
and nolan
um yeah it's uh it's where it's worth
give it a spin i think you'll dig you
break it up with it
chunks if you break it up into 22 minute
chunks you can watch it
for four years so true
um folks there's your post
christmas i guess this is the last time
is this the last time we do it before
the
year changes probably i would think so
yeah i think i think it is um let me see
december 20. yeah
that's true all right so uh
next week we'll do it on january 2nd on
saturday
it's my birthday show we'll do a show on
my birthday january 2nd
it's my 40th birthday which we're i'm
going to do the show
what i was supposed to be doing is
traveling
to all the star wars filming locations
that was going to be my 40th birthday
present to myself
and then i had a baby and covid
so instead i'm going to be doing fat man
beyond
let's do a uh we'll do you know last
what was it we raised money for who last
time or
um you know stand up together stand up
cancer and one other time we raise money
for the
the small book bank
this time uh jc's 40th birthday benefit
like we'll just the same way we like
raise money for a good cause we'll just
raise
[ __ ] a bunch of money i mean look it all
goes to the [ __ ] bar and [ __ ] so
next week saturday kids our
new year's show the first show of 2021
oh bring your [ __ ] open hearts and
open wallets
to go fund me for jason yeah put
together some loot for jc
for his eventual trip which he's not
going to get to take for quite some time
you can't go on that trip with that
little [ __ ] kid man holy [ __ ]
yeah it'll be 50 now is
[Laughter]
um yeah all right so that's we'll do
next week on
saturday we'll do this again and it'll
be 2021 kids can you imagine
something dreamed about since [ __ ]
like february of 2020
like when's this horrible [ __ ] year
gonna end it's about to end and we're
gonna be in the future
next week so until then happy new year
everybody merry christmas
and happy new year happy holidays and
stuff we'll see on the other side
god willing it's all still here and what
huh um
go watch tennant go watch wonder woman
1984
for fat man beyond i'm kevin smith
i'm mark bernard tune in next week same
fat times aim fat channels modcast.com
or
youtube.com kevin smith
um uh wakanda forever
this is the way
you